I'm Callie a reading for reviewer
Richard way cling code vain establishes
its own identity from the outset it may
latch on to a Dark Souls formula that
has come to define a generation of
action RPGs but it manages to set itself
apart from the rest by presenting a
post-apocalyptic world filled with what
are essentially anime vampires
[Music]
interesting concepts and mechanics
filter out from the central blood-soaked
idea resulting in a game that feels
familiar yet wildly different from the
souls games that inspired it yet it's
the parts that are most recognizable
such as its combat work code fate and
stumbles after an apocalyptic Cataclysm
ravages the world those who died are
brought back to life as immortal beings
called revenants the price they have to
pay for reincarnation is an insatiable
thirst for blood
fortunately a revenant don't have to
feed on the few remaining humans to
survive blood beads grow on plants
throughout the world and function as
suitable substitutes for human blood
nourishing a revenant bloodlust in much
the same way the problem is blood beads
are becoming increasingly sparse so it's
up to you to find the source and
hopefully attain a steady supply in
stereotypical protagonist fashion you
begin the game by waking up with amnesia
before finding out you're the chosen one
you see each revenant and code vein has
a class known as a blood code your
created character is special because
they're not confined to a single blood
code like everyone else's this
malleability allows you to swap between
various classes whenever you feel like
it with your arsenal of available blood
codes expanding the further you progress
throughout the game blood codes are
tailored to a specific style of play
that often fits into a typical RPG class
template think warrior or mage gifts are
code veins version of abilities granting
you access to a wide range of passive
and active skills that are tied but not
limited to each Blood code you're able
to mix and match gifts to a certain
degree with the most exciting ones
letting you unleash flashy special
attacks in melee combat others allow you
to fire projectiles of piercing Ike or
boost your attack power or temporarily
add a stun effect to your weapon and
there are many more the character
creator is already comprehensive enough
but code Vayne provides a plethora of
options when it comes to finding a play
style that suits you incorporating gifts
amid regular attacks makes for some
satisfying combos and there's a
gratifying heft behind each slash and
crunch of code Bane's melee combat
each gift consumes from a pool of I core
that's replenished by simply defeating
enemies or refilled in larger doses by
performing drain attacks parries and
back steps this incentivizes you to use
gifts regularly approaching each enemy
with an offensive mindset twin leash a
bevy of special attacks and then quickly
regain any lost I core wailing on
enemies is satisfying and gifts spruce
up each fight with their inherent
flexibility yet combat is a
disappointingly by-the-numbers affair
because of the AI shortcomings there's
an adequate variety of enemy types but
this variety generally only applies to
their visual design as opposed to their
behavior and movesets
they're surprisingly static spending
most of their time simply idling instead
of reacting to your attacks each weapon
you wield is usually able to stagger
enemies on the first or second hit
allowing you to dispatch each foe with
almost no resistance and this remains
true throughout the entirety of the game
there are a few enemies that break away
from this mould requiring you to
actually dodge and make use of your
gifts but they're an anomaly amid a sea
of one-sided slugfest bosses aren't
quite as easy to take down but they're
not far from it there are no patterns to
learn or delicate back-and-forth setting
compass every aspect of code veins
combat it's simple enough to be each
boss on your first your second attempt
by simply maneuvering behind them this
only deviates as you approach the end
credits and bosses receive a sudden
difficulty spike as they rely on
powerful area-of-effect tax and homing
projectiles code Vayne doesn't have to
adhere darksouls challenging difficulty
but it also misses the mark by never
forcing you to learn or deepen your
understanding of the game to progress
combat devolves into a mindless task or
the only thing you need to watch out for
is enemy placement and quantity
exploring each environment is engaging
at least the level design has a tendency
to wrap in and around itself offering
secret paths and capturing the elation
that's derived from opening a shortcut
or discovering a new checkpoint to rest
at one sprawling area even borrows an
Orlando's distinct Ile Duomo inspired
aesthetic reimagining the pearly white
castle as a labyrinth in maze it's just
a shame the visual design is regularly
pedestrian you spend the vast majority
of your time traversing through bland
post-apocalyptic streets and damp caves
were a rumble as code veins most
distinguishing feature the
of fire and sand shakes up the typical
dilapidated cityscape but it's not
nearly enough to shake the feeling that
you've seen it all before there's even a
late area that adopts the anor londo
aesthetic for a second time the only
difference is that now it's inside and
slightly darker moving through an area
that conjures memories of Dark Souls
most memorable location doesn't do code
vain any favors it adopts the souls like
formula and its structure presenting a
familiar cycle of progression and basic
combat similarities and there are some
interesting ideas here - built around
the use of various blood codes and their
distinct gifts you can see the fragments
of a fantastic game hidden within these
systems and it's meaty combat feedback
but the mundanity of its enemies and the
effect they have on nullifying the
combats enjoyment prevents code Vayne
from ever realizing it's potential
you
[Music]